hi everybody the one and only Lady Gaga
tearfully surprised fans at a screening
for her new film a star is born in New
York City it was like so excited to see
the movie there you guys are a very
special advanced screening Gaga very
much wished that she could be a part of
this and her wish came true please
welcome the star of the star is born
[Applause]
hi everybody the one and only hi I love
you so much thank you so so much from
the bottom of my heart for being here
tonight so we have a few questions we
wanted to ask you about the movie about
this experience we're about to meet Ali
what are some traits about Ali that you
are so excited to be bringing to this
audience well actually to be totally
honest Ali and I are very different you
know when I decided that I wanted to go
for it as a musician as a
singer-songwriter and my friends were
calling me gaga
I and I was ready to take the reins I
was so confident I wanted to be myself I
had something to say I was hitting the
ground running dragging my keyboard
around New York City banging on every
door that I could to get a gig and Ali
is is not like this and you will see
this tonight she's in her 30s
she's jaded by the music industry she's
been told that she's not beautiful
enough and that she can't make it and
she has no self confidence you'll see
that it's Jackson's love for her that
changes her life and I will say that
there can be a hundred people in a room
maybe there is right now and 99 don't
believe in you
but all you need is just for one person
to believe so I have to say thank you to
my incredible director Bradley Cooper
for being that one person but also it
would be a lie
to not think each and every one of you
who have supported me over the years I
would not be here without you
[Applause]
Oh
I love that thank you we've seen you do
jazz we've seen you do pop in metal and
rock and everything in between what is a
genre you'd love to dabble in next LG
said I don't know if that'll be my next
record okay okay
we'll stick around for it don't worry
what do you hope this version your
version how do you hope it impacts this
generation honestly this is the moment
that Bradley gives the film over to you
and to the world and my hope surely is
that it touches you all in a variety of
ways it will touch everyone differently
I speak to so many different people and
everyone comes away from this film with
something different but I am so grateful
and I am so humbled that it is moving
people and that's all that matters
so this is our gift to you we love you
and and thank you so much for inspiring
us thank you everyone
Lady gaga
and how about a big round of applause
for Tyler as well for doing this tonight
this is so special I hope you enjoy the
film I love you all so very much
[Applause]